my life should not be
made up of mistakes that were out of my
control
ashley was just 15 when social services
had to find her a place to live
they sent her to a caravan she had
support staff
around the clock who were meant to look
after her
there was an incident
um a couple walked in to our caravan
and they'd been making home-brewed
alcohol
so i'd drank it and some of the staff
had as well i'd had about two or three
drinks
and i started to feel like i was about
to pass out which was not
normal for me at that point like and i
had them shut the door and lock it
and i just i knew something wasn't right
i took my chance and i ran
i thought i was in like real danger at
that point that my
life could have been in danger as well
ashley is one of thousands of children
placed into homes
that are unregulated that means they're
not inspected
but they are in demand because there's a
serious shortage
of places to house vulnerable children
today the education secretary gavin
williamson
said these places will be banned for
under 16s
but he's under pressure to do more i
have asked him to go further
and actually ban that provision for any
child under 18 because if they're in
care
then those are the most vulnerable
children who need the most support
there should be no instance where a
child
under the age of 18 who is in the care
of the state should be left
without proper supervision proper
support and the regulation around it to
ensure
that they're safeguarded against harm
an investigation by sky news has
revealed the scale of the problem
we asked councils how many under 18s
they'd placed in unregulated homes
86 replied between january 2019
and the end of 2020 they placed almost
10 000 children there we discovered that
17 were sent to hotels and b and b's
five were sent to holiday parks seven
were placed in
barges an independent review into the
children's social care system is now
underway
it's expected to take 18 months and it's
headed by josh mcallister
so the basic test for me is can we
create a system here
which better guarantees for every single
child growing up in england
safety stability and love is the sort of
bedrock of being able to go on and have
a successful future
when they look at you do they see
another guy coming along carrying out
review and publishing it in a big
fanfare
well can you look them in the eye and
promise them real change i can
and they're going to have to judge me
quite rightly that they should by
the results of this review the
government say what happened to you
should never happen again why is it
important
that they actually follow through that
promise
it is damaging to the people that are
placing them
situations to point where i can just
destroy someone's life
the government's ban on unregulated
accommodation for under 16s
won't actually come into force until
september
that means thousands of children will be
placed in potentially
unsafe homes between now and then nick
martin sky news